hey guys Pete here it's time for a new
weekly spoiler report and I have some
stuff to talk about that we got this
week if you don't like spoilers about
production or Game of Thrones set news
then you'll want to stop watching this
video however we do have a book giveaway
going on and I have a non spoiler video
from this week you can watch about how
many episodes of the series Game of
Thrones are left everyone else stick
around to the end so that you can enter
and let's jump into it so right after I
uploaded last week spoiler report I saw
a photo from a hiker basically who was
in Iceland climbing a glacier and came
across the Game of Thrones set and
snapped a couple pictures it's pretty
cool story and the pictures were quite
nice but it doesn't really reveal much
of anything of importance or at least
anything that we didn't already know
before these pics came out Ian Glen had
popped up in Iceland so there was a good
idea that he'd be filming there which we
saw we also already knew that Gendry the
actor who plays Gendry was in town and
because we had so much information from
Oak Hill we sort of knew that all these
characters were going to be together
shooting once Kit Harington got there in
the first place but it is nice to have
photos from different sources and one
person saw Jorah walking and I guess
maybe taking a break having a cigarette
and one of the landscape scenes and then
the other one the original one I saw the
actual poster interacted with some of
the people who commented and pointed out
the different actors that she spotted on
the set as you can see in the photos
there are about nine people dressed for
winter which if we count off the people
we know to be involved leaves a couple
extra so if you want to count along with
me we have Jon Snow Gendry Soros and
Jorah that we all saw there in person
during war pill we had tormund and the
Hound spotted and also barrack which we
haven't actually seen yet but you know
we know he's Lee or the Brotherhood
and he went there with torment in the
hound so that means that there's
probably two unknown people here if not
more but they could be just about
anybody I mean torment could be
traveling with companions from beyond
the wall and more importantly if we
think back to what we do know about it
we saw the boat take off from the
Dragonstone area way back when they were
shooting there and there were a couple
companions in the boat who we weren't
exactly sure who they were so this isn't
likely some big reveal it's probably
just supporters of the characters we
already know and speaking of the Hound
Rory McCann was actually seen by
somebody later in the week in Iceland so
we can assume that one of those people
is him you know going beyond what the
original poster on Twitter had mentioned
these pictures were great but there was
even some more interesting ones that
came out later I saw them yesterday and
I'm not sure if they have been reported
on yet but I'm guessing by the time you
watch this video you'll probably be
articles about these other photos they
were originally posted on Instagram and
then someone from the free folk
subreddit posted them there of course I
saw them from reddit first they're from
far away and they're on the beach so we
see that there's boats involved but
there's a couple characters here that if
you zoom in it's not exactly clear who
they are and to me it almost looks like
they're white walkers now why they would
be there isn't entirely clear or really
anything isn't entirely clear here but
there's these two strange characters and
you know there's the outside chance that
they could be like maybe unsullied you
know because they have a spear and the
shield but looking at their heads it
doesn't look anything like a shaved head
unsullied who would be wearing a helmet
unless there's some weird light play
going on it to me that the one on the
right especially looks like one of the
white walkers that we've seen in the
past not a white but that's just
completely speculation based on a photo
that I zoomed in a bunch on so let me
know what you guys think about that the
actual poster of this who put it on
Instagram originally says that he
a fan of the show or hasn't followed in
any way so he didn't add anything except
for that you know he knew it was the
Game of Thrones crew filming they're the
original poster on reddit was why I 150
or ye 150 so if you want to look at what
people were saying about it you can just
go over to the free folk subreddit and
check it out
Watchers on the wall also reported that
the band Bastille is supposed to make an
appearance in this season one of the
cameos that we've seen in the past they
reported that even though filming had
wrapped up it will feel that the band
was actually spotted there and in a
recent interview they did was Vogue or
at least the lead singer did he
mentioned that he was going to get to
check out the set of Game of Thrones
soon so if you're a fan of Bastille this
should be exciting of course I never
heard of them so I did watch the video
where sophie turner lip-synchs the song
and that was kind of interesting and
like I said if you're a fan this is
probably good news and the final big
thing we got this week which is probably
the most reported on I'm guessing you
probably seen it on one of the many
different places that are running
articles about it now it was an
exclusive from Watchers on the wall who
reported it first and they talked about
the fact that the actor David Bradley
who plays Walder Frey had updated his
resume or CV to include season seven of
Game of Thrones
now obviously Walder Frey himself was
killed in in the final episode of season
six and there is a little bit of
weirdness here because he has a season
two on his resume instead of season
three which is whenever you know the big
red wedding and all that happened but
this is not likely an addition that
would be a mistake I mean it said one
two and six and then all of a sudden
they added seven on to it so my initial
reaction was okay well he's going to be
laying in a coffin and the other phrase
who remain will be there you know
watching and talking about their plans
but if you think about that it doesn't
really fit into anything about the story
for so initially I was kind of surprised
that Watchers on the wall had said that
I mean they basically tied it to the
leaks that came from reddit a few months
ago now I know a lot of you guys are
leak averse so I'm not going to exactly
say what they're referring to but here's
what we know we know that Bradley is
supposed to be coming back and playing a
role in season seven the character he
plays is dead so somehow we have to
assume that a character whose story is
important moving forward to the end of
the series we'll have some contact or
interaction or whatever with Walder Frey
that brings him into the story so
logically you can might you might think
that bran would see him in a vision or
something like that but the only thing
he would see there might be the red
wedding and everybody already knows that
is how that went down like there's no
reveal there so if he's not lying in
state and he's not actually alive
there's the obvious conclusion that
people have speculated on in the past
that may be REM might steal his face we
know that she's important going forward
we know that she killed Walder Frey and
we know that she just trained with the
faceless men so it's a pretty believable
speculation but we'll have to find out
what old Walder Frey is doing in season
seven when we get more information
piggybacking on that Maisie Williams did
do an interview this week because she
has a new limited series I think coming
out on Netflix called
AI boy but she did talk a little bit of
Game of Thrones she didn't give anything
away as far as the what Arya is going to
be up to necessarily but she did sort of
slip in there that she hadn't read the
scripts for season 8 yet which would be
a good indication that she expects to
read them now I had never thought that
Arya might die in season 7 but it's good
to know that she's probably going to not
die if that makes any sense she's always
been one of the characters that we
expected would make it to the end her
and brand so at least now we have a
pretty good hint that she will be making
it through this season if
season seven and season eight one other
little interesting story came out Carla
tell who plays Varys was talking to The
Huffington Post and he revealed that he
was actually that he actually read for
Robert Baratheon at the same time that
he read for Varys
so think about how much different that
would have been I mean the only you know
I really think of this guy is Varys and
even when I reread stuff from the books
when I'm thinking about Paris I'm
thinking about Karma tell so pretty good
pretty happy that it turned out this way
personally so that's about it please
chime in on what you think about the new
photos from Iceland and what you think
about what Walder Frey is going to be
doing coming back in season 7 please
like the video if you enjoyed it and
don't forget to subscribe if you want to
enter the book giveaway this is my
second book giveaway now and this time
when I reach 28 thousand subscribers I
will pick one comment from one of these
videos where I mention the giveaway and
send that commenter a copy of the 20th
anniversary edition of a game of Thrones
by George Martin it's simple to
subscribe it's simple the comments so go
ahead and do it that's it for this week
I got some other stuff coming out soon
so thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon